Astro Boy, Dragon Ball, Akira, Sailor Moon,
Demon Slayer, Death Note all these interesting,
iconic anime have something very much in common
they started off as : manga.
Manga, by its most simplistic definition,
are comics or graphic novels originating from
Japan, which became extremely popular in the
United States starting in the 80s and 90s.
We’ve already touched on Western Graphic
Novels and Comics, but you know we couldn’t
just leave it at that (not with this t-shirt).
So today we’re discussing manga as its own
rich literature, reflecting the complicated
political history of Japan.
So before we get started, for all my fellow
otakus out there—manga as a genre is massive,
and if we don’t discuss your favorite title,
sorry not sorry.
Manga tends to be broken up by age and demographic,
with one creator responsible for both illustrating
and writing the story: The most popular are:
Shōjo manga—girls 9–18
Shōnen manga—boys 9–18
Josei manga—adult women
Seinen manga—adult men
Yuri/GL/girls love—lesbian themes
Yaoi/shonen ai/BL—gay themes
While manga has been read by Japanese audiences
across the board, it’s had a long road to
the popularity it now has in the US - it’s
only fairly recently that graphic novels were
recognized for their potential as high art
here, but manga has been recognized as valid
art and entertainment for all ages basically
since WWII.
Many magazines and publications surround themselves
around crafting stories for whatever their
demographic.
However, there is always room for crossover
and shonen has been, for as long as I’ve
been alive, the most popular “genre” of
manga.
According to Professor of Japanese Literature
Adam Kern, the first use of the term manga
happened in 1798 referring to the work of
poet/writer/artist Santō Kyōden.
However, manga as we know today didn’t exist
just yet.
The first character of the word “manga”
is often interpreted as “whimsical” or
“inconsequential,” so the word is frequently
translated as generously “whimsical pictures”.
But what would eventually come to be known
as manga started off as political cartoons.
In the 1100s, a high ranking Buddhist priest
named Kakuyū or Toba Sōjō produced a series
of anthropomorphized animals doing human activities
to throw shade on the less devout priests.
Love that for him.
The first Japanese magazine for children was
The Youth’s World, which ran from 1895 to
1914 and in 1902 a girls’ magazine, Girls’
Kingdom, was launched.
The precursors to Shonen Jump and Shojo Beat.
Rakuten Kitazawa, artist and political cartoonist,
was the first person to use the word manga
in its modern sense and is widely regarded
in Japan as the father of modern manga and
everything it would become today.
He launched several magazines, including the
highly influential Tokyo Puck and was the
first manga author (or as we would say, mangaka)
to have his work turned into toys and a children’s
card game to boot.
Then … we got Norakuro … the orphan pup,
a Felix the Cat expy that had adventures with
many characters even Mickey thee Mouse because
copyright laws were weird back then and the
creator of Norakuro, Suiho Tagawa, did not
care.
But a shift truly came on January 1st 1946
when Osamu Tezuka-sama, the manga god himself
released his first book-length project, Shin
Takarajima or New Treasure Island, which was
based on the classic novel by Robert Louis
Stevenson.
It was the beginning of several hits and a
very long career, since he was just seventeen
at the time of his first publication.
While during WWII his work had been dismissed
as “unpatriotic” because he wasn’t totally
in step with the japanese imperial propaganda
line, he ended up becoming the creator of
Astro Boy, Princess Knight, Kimba the White
Lion (Leave us your Disney opinions!! #engagement),
and Dororo.
That is only a few of the over 700 manga titles
for adults and children, over 100 animated
films and TV series, alongside novels, essays,
designs, and illustrations he produced until
his death in 1989.
From the autobiography of Osamu Tezuka:
“I made a point of depicting a movement
or facial expression with many frames, even
many pages…
The result was a super-long comic that ran
to 500, 600, even 1,000 pages…
I also believed that comics were capable of
more than just making people laugh.
So in my themes I incorporated tears, grief,
anger, and hate, and I created stories where
the ending was not always ‘happy.’”
Not bad for a kid who was once beaten for
writing manga.
Tezuka’s Princess Knight is considered to
be the first adventure manga series for girls.
It told the story of Sapphire, a princess
who must pretend to be a prince in order to
inherit the throne of Silverland as women
are not eligible to do so.
The character’s androgynous-like design
would be the inspiration for other heroines
as the leads in popular shojo series like
Rose of Versailles and Revolutionary Girl
Utena.
Cutie Honey by Go Nagai in 1973, became one
of the, if not the first, shōnen manga with
a female protagonist.
Cutie Honey told the story of a 16-year-old
schoolgirl/andorid who would transform into
a busty heroine to save the world.
Yup, that sounds like a manga.
Cutie Honey is one of the foremothers of the
magical girl genre, my personal favorite.
The post-war generation took manga and its
foundations and transformed it into the medium
with titles we are familiar with today.
According to humanities professor Jennifer
Prough (prew):
“Manga grew up alongside the first generation
of postwar children.
The fledgling industry struggled for its footing
in the early years, providing much needed
entertainment for the children of the fifties
and early sixties.
As those children grew older, they continued
to be enamored with manga, and the genre expanded
into teen and then adult titles.[...].
For a time manga was considered at best pulp
fiction and at worst a danger to young children,
but by the eighties, manga was embraced as
national culture.”
In the 80s, just like everywhere else cyberpunk
would take over the world and in manga two
titles in particular: Akira and Ghost in the
Shell.
Katsuhiro Otomo’s Akira began its eight-year
run [remember when that was a long time] in
1982.
The story begins ten years into the then future
of 1992, with an apparent nuclear explosion
that destroys Tokyo and starts World War III.
Then we jump to 2019, in the new city of Neo-Tokyo,
disaffected biker gangs and rioting factions
clash in the streets.
In the ruins of old Tokyo, two childhood friends
are sucked into a military and political plot
of terrifying dimensions.
So basically, it predicted 2019 really well.
The movie version of Akira was the entry point
for anime’s breakthrough into English-speaking
culture.
Which led to manga and anime becoming more
and more popular.
Professor of Japanese Literature Christopher
Bolton wrote in, Interpreting Anime:
“For some critics, Akira represents a fixation
on destruction that supposedly lies at the
heart of Japanese popular culture, a legacy
of the atomic bomings.
This reading suggests Hiroshima and Nagasaki
as original traumas that are then worked out
and mastered through their repetition in popular
culture.”
In 1989, Ghost in the Shell, arrived on the
scene.
Detailing a possible future where computer
technology has advanced to the point that
many members of the public possess cyberbrains
that allow them to interface their biological
brain
with various networks.
This manga was hugely influential -- leading
to an anime that be a breakout outside of
Japan, inspiring films like the Matrix, to
…. [scarlet johansen movie] yeah.
But we gotta get to it, the manga that really
started the nerd revolution that we have all
suffered under.
[singing the Dragon Ball Z theme song]
In December 1984, Akira Toriyama’s Dragon
Ball appeared in Weekly Shonen Jump.
And since then everyone has debated who Goku
can and can not beat up.
Dragon Ball is, without question the shonen
series of our lifetime.
Like it or not, those characters have laid
the foundation for everything.
For those who don’t know, Dragon Ball is
about a young warrior named Goku, who starts
off a rascal kid with a monkey tail and slowly
finds out through spin-offs that he is one
of the remaining survivors of a warrior race
called the Saiyans who were wiped out by a
metrosexual space-alien.
The series started off as a riff on the Monkey
King legend and has turned into one of the
weirdest space/martial arts/comedy shounen
series of all time.
From Dragon Ball we get: Naruto, Bleach, One
Piece, JoJo’s Bizarre Adventure, YuYu Hakusho,
Rurouni Kenshin, and many others.
Still, despite the dominance of shonen in
the marketplace one of the first manga series
to break into the bestsellers list was Fruits
Basket by Natsuki Takaya.
Fruits Basket is a shōjo series about a sweet
girl named Torhu who helps members of a family
deal with their terrible parental relationships.
Also, they have a zodiac curse that makes
them turn into animals when a member of the
opposite sex touches them.
It’s really good.
The sixteenth volume of the English release
rose to the 15th position on the USA Today
Top 150 Bestselling Books, which was the highest
position ever achieved by a volume of manga
in the United States at the time.
The final volume of the English adaptation
was a New York Times bestseller in the summer
of 2009, moving from #2 to #1 in the list
during the weeks of July 12–25.
Girls - Who run this world … shojo Take
that Naruto
According to religious studies professor Mark.
W. MacWilliams, “In the case of the U.S.,
since 1999, manga sales have taken off, mainly
because the popularity of anime paved the
way for manga that served as their source
of inspiration.”
So this was all neat, but why are we here
talking about manga?
Well, because
manga is literature.
It ranges in theme and genre and maturity
levels, but just like with graphic novels,
many titles are rich storytelling devices
filled with allegory and metaphor about humanity.
Jean-Marie Bouissou, a french historian, broke
it down in his essay: “Manga: A Historical
Overview”:
“Manga owes its influence to its ability
to keep pace with new developments in society
and attitudes, as illustrated by three changes
in the genres inherited from the defeat and
nuclear traumas: the post-apocalyptic, the
mecha, and the so-called “scientific adventure.
[...] mecha’s simplistic clashes between
big machines gave way to an exploration of
the existentialist worries of their young
controllers, including girls, who now have
leading roles--just as they do in Akira.”
What’s more is that with the popularity
of manga (and anime) there can be a desire
to separate the genre from it’s Japanese
roots or on the flip side, fetitishize it.
Tracing the history of manga we can see how
the genre evolved as Japan was forced out
of isolation into trading with the west.
The post-WWII environment and its aftermath.
Professor of Japanese Language and Culture
Jaqueline Berndt, put it aptly: “I would
like to point to an “economic Japaneseness”
here, that is, manga as an extraordinarily
successful culture industry.[...]
This system of production, which has been
evolving since the late 1950s, has had many
aesthetic and cultural consequences.
[...] These are specifically Japanese aspects
that derive from particular historic conditions,
and they should lead one to realize that “manga”
and “comic books'' connote completely different
cultures of publishing, distributing, and
consuming comics”
You don’t get certain titles without the
context of life in Japan.
So, Sailor Moon says: appreciate manga not
just for the fight scenes and the fun transformations,
but for the insight and access it gives you
into another culture.
Also, Sailor Moon would kick Goku’s butt.
However, they would probably rather hang out
and eat, than fight anyway.
If you like It’s Lit, you should check out
Otherwords, the newest addition to the Storied
family!
Otherwords dives deep into the world of linguistics
and language.
Have you ever wondered about what makes words,
well, words?
What about how computers “talk,” or the
unique characteristics of different dialects?
Check out Otherwords (and be sure to tell
them that It’s Lit sent you).
Link in the description below.